we lost one of our people this week that
we love so much Aaron Carter I know he
was here with you guys back on season 9.
[Music]
I saw the news and I was shocked it's a
true tragedy because he was just a very
innocent to me he's like an innocent
young child and when he was on the show
he was like a child just kind of
becoming a man and I will always
remember him for being this beautiful
bright light that seemed to be
misunderstood and I felt like on Dancing
With the Stars he had this moment where
people could see him in his fullest
sense he was shining and he was free and
he was like starting new chapters and it
was just I'll always remember that about
him he is somebody who like sits right
here in my heart and I think of him all
the time so I was heartbroken and my
love and my condolences to his family
but he will be missed because he was a
very special sweet carousel
[Music]
yo Trev what's the 4-1-1 it's Maggie's
night let's talk about 90s for a second
because it gets this place lit well
there's a lot of shirtlessness happening
tonight right I mean when Derek takes
off his shirt and then Bruno starts to
we got to stop the party for a second
because it's getting out of control it
was getting so out of control I was
watching from the parking lot and I
started undressing I was like why am I
doing this I can't stop myself we got
the 90s gear the 90s music talk about
some of the live performances I mean
this was a killer show this was an
amazing show
salt and peppers in the house we got the
90s in the house Make Some Noise 90s are
like my favorite time of my life I know
I'm telling a lot by saying that but you
know the 90s were the bomb and it was
great to have salt and Peppa and Vogue
Vanilla Ice Kid and Play I watch house
party so many times and the songs
tonight like everyone I was like you
need to judge you cannot just get up and
have your own personal dance party you
must judge and focus let's talk about
that for a second the relay judging do
you do you love it do you enjoy it is it
the best thing ever or what I love it I
hate it I love it I hate it it's a very
mixed bag of tricks and a lot of emotion
there and I had a hard time choosing
obviously I was like I don't know what
to do
um
honestly
I don't like it
there's nothing to like about it you
know I could feel their emotions and
like they worked so hard and everybody
tonight left it on that floor I mean
really it was it's the competition's
close and tonight was powerful did you
see people up their games like they took
Leaps and Bounds yes tonight was my
favorite show by far and they're all
good 90s for life can we do 90s again
next week please 90s again and again and
again and again Carrie Anne we love you
so much but please tell me about this
dress you're wearing it's a little black
Halo
Halo Asian Barbies that's all that's
something I just want to say I know
there there is one but I think we could
use a few more where's our Chinese
Korean Vietnamese there's a whole bunch
of us Filipino there's a lot of us we
could make plenty more I mean you're a
Barbie right now this is a carrion
Barbie right who can also fly girl going
into the semifinals who's a favorite who
should be scared tell me where we're at
going to the semifinals
sorry as you can tell there's a lot
going on okay I think Charlie and Wayne
set the bar really high tonight but I
will say that at this point it's
anyone's game yeah because what you need
to do is stand out and have impact
and you can do that even if you're not
necessarily the best technician or have
been delivering tens this whole time you
can come out from behind
and wow us and leave impact this is a
really tough competition it's tight you
felt it you were in the room yeah for
sure I mean it's definitely anybody's
game I agree with you 100 I I don't want
anybody to go home every week I don't
want anybody to go home but we're gonna
have a lot of dances next week so be
prepared it's gonna be good
[Music]